Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Conner's again talking about module two in this stop fighting
cancer course. In this module I'm going to give you a brief overview of our Conner's method
and understand there's a lot of information in this I'm really shaking it down please make sure
you download a free copy of my stop fighting cancer and start reading the causebook because that can
be a wealth of information for you as well. Plus I have several other books that you'll want to download
and look at as you go through these modules just to remind or for you the detoxification book
makes it really helpful when you start getting into some of the our methods our pillars that we're
talking about here and then dealing with that spiritual side and that emotional side
is such a key what you're dealing with a serious disease you don't want to ignore that.
So let's go over what I have labeled a number of years ago when I first started
reading cancer back in the late 1990s oh yeah it seems like a long time ago and the early 2000s
that came up with what I called the four pillars. Now there's there's a lot in each one of these
pillars so we could expand it to be the 24 pillars but I'm trying to keep this simple in understanding
these pieces because I do believe that when you're dealing with a serious disease you already got
enough going through your head that you don't need to be confused we got to keep this simple
so and our approach is simple some people have complained that it's too simple but if you don't
keep it simple people don't stay on things and people don't stick with things and then well what
good is that then they don't have results at all so you have to keep it simple and easy to do
and is least disruptive in a person's lifestyle or no matter how motivated you are to start we're
going to juice 12 glasses of juice a day and we're going to you know go on a complete ketogenic diet
and we're going to do all this stuff it becomes so life disrupting that that isn't good for us
in a lot of ways if we come we could actually make an idol oh no treating our cancer or our disease
and then that becomes very spiritual a big spiritual issue or we could make it so complicated that we
can't stick with it and we can have that motivation for a period of time and then it weeds and
wades quickly and after a couple weeks we're so exhausted from trying to treat treat our cancer treat
our disease that we're sick from that and you know dealing with myself personally and dealing with
patients you know back as the last 27 years it's the easier that you can make it in the least life
disrupting that you can make it the better results we get which seems kind of ironic shouldn't we be
taking 47 different bottles of supplements at three of them three times a day makes you 150 supplements a
day and have to follow this diet and do all these procedures and go to these clinics and get IVs and
do all this in order to get better because I'm really sick well there's truth that we do need to do
some things there is a work on our part if we're going to get better from being sick we do have to change
lifestyle things but the least disruptive you can make it the better it's going to be because you'll stick
to it it doesn't have to be a grandiose change to make a big difference and that's the key it doesn't
have to be a grandiose change to make a big difference a lot of people especially men are really happy
to hear that because men got a lot of things on their mind already not that women don't but they tend
to be less focused on their body and you know being able to stick to a diet maybe it's just our makeup
I don't know what it is women tend to be much better disciplined at those things but we want to keep
this a very doable procedure so as we go through these four pillars I'm going to give an overview
in this module and then in the following modules we're going to dig deep into each one of these
things our first pillar is to address the cause we talked about that already my book is titled that stop
fighting cancer and start treating the cause and I titled it that way because that was my philosophy
from the very beginning with my first cancer patient we're not going to have this fight I don't think
that's healthy if we're fighting something in our body and I understand I've seen these these
you know blank cancer bumper stickers up the out there and people can get very emotional when
they're dealing with a serious disease that could kill them and they can get angry and they can
become bitter or they can they can have these emotions and I and I realize that can be healthy to go
through those but we have to go through them we have to come out at the other end and take a more
pragmatic pragmatic position in that okay now what am I going to do about this um fighting and being
angry at our cancer I don't think solves the problem I think we need to take a step back and look
at it there are causes to cancer remember cancer is something got inside of a cell one cell
and interrupted the cellular replication in the nucleus of that cell and now that cell is
replicated uncontrollably divided and divided and divided replicated at a much greater rate than
what is normal normally most cells will divide will replicate and then the mother cells eventually
die off through a process called apoptosis normal program cell death which is basically a recycling
of that cell matter to be used throughout the body but when that doesn't happen and a cell goes into
rapid replication mode because of something that got inside of that cell then we're in trouble so
we do want to address that cause what was it that got inside that cell was it was it a biotoxid was
it a virus was it a bacteria was it a pesticide herbicide what is tied to that also the pieces of
cause is it driven by hormones is it driven by a bad environment we want to address those pieces it's
funny that medicine is very good at looking at causes of cancer when they do all these studies on
well this causes cancer this causes cancer and you you know hardly a week goes by without you see
another cause of cancer but then how come when somebody gets cancer that is never addressed
never have I had anybody come to me that says hey I found out I have cancer and it's because of a
pesticide they don't they don't look for that even though hey pesticides are probably the number one
cause of lymphomas and leukemias but never had a lymphoma patient come and tell me that
so we want to look for that there's a ways to test for that and we'll talk about that in the next
module actually and then we want to address the cancer itself that's that's pillar number two we do
need to find a nutraceutical from our perspective an herbal or a homeopathic protocol that's going to be
best suited for that person's body to stimulate the immune system to kill the cancer we want to
address the cancer not just taking care of the cause but we have to address the cancer and we have
to do it in a way that we're not using a ton of stuff in the least amount of things possible again
keeping it simple keeping it doable keeping it that you can continue to do this on a regular basis
when the motivation starts to wane and then we want to use technology we use rife technology we use
pdf technology we use hyperthermia hyperbaric there's technology out there that can help the body
the immune system attack the cancer to be rife technology is the best as far as getting the body
to focus on that cancer part of the reason why your immune system doesn't kill a cancer is that
the cancer cell is still self-tissue it's still your own cells and your immune system is programmed
to not kill self-tissue so you've got to get the immune system the T cells the macrophages the
natural killer cells to be able to attack that cancer that's growing out of control that rapid
replication of cells and you do that with hitting it with its own frequencies you're causing it to
vibrate you're causing the immune system to refocus on that and look at that again to go oh my gosh
what is that maybe we need to take a second look maybe we need to kill that rapidly growing mass
so we do rife programming specific to that cancer so that person's body can best help kill the
cancer and personally i believe using rife helps immune products nutraceuticals and things help target
the cancer and even chemotherapy and immunotherapy it helps the target the cancer so that's my personal
opinion i have no research to prove that but we've seen that in our practice so i think rife is
invaluable i don't think i'd be standing here talking to you right now if i didn't use a rife machine
so i think a rife machine isn't valuable and you need one that's going to be able to penetrate
the body and be easiest to use and we'll go into that in detail in coming modules as well and then
lastly you need to clean up the terrain we talked about this in the last module gave a really neat
picture of a fish in a dirty take and a fish in a clean tank real easy picture to understand that
your terrain your environment is super important that environment to where that cancer is growing
needs to be cleaned that's the process detoxification that's a process of just natural healing
lot to talk about pH balance but cancer is growing in a rapid state causing an acidic environment
at that cancer so we need to detoxify and clean that area out so those are the four pillars that we're
going to dive into in these modules stick with me here download my book as i said download my detoxification
book and my cancer can't kill you if you're already dead book start dealing with the emotional
spiritual side start dealing with the with the detox understanding detoxification of the seven phases
of detoxification how important that is those things you start doing these things no matter if you're
choosing standards of care along with this or not will help you tremendously all right I just pray
that this is a blessing to all of you and we'll see you at the next module